but then we're also just assuming that  every man is going to be like  you're worthless oh i'm not i'm not  assuming every man but i think that like  majority okay  would you would you prefer a girl that  has slept with a hundred people or slept  with ten  especially for me ten yeah yeah and like  i think if you ask like yeah guys would  you prefer someone more pure or more  more of a hoe most guys are going to say  more pure yeah but then you see for a  relationship yeah but then you see who  and what people then you see who and  what people watch on social media or  porn or who they engage with and you're  like oh you're a hot celebrity or  someone with a lot of followers or  someone who is very desirable or someone  who is and that's it nothing is black  and white the one thing i say about that  is i i understand about the whole  desirable thing but guys don't really  care  how much  a girl is desired by other men that  seems to be more